auto scaling helps you size up to handle
increased demand and
size down to avoid paying for resources
that you're not using
that's not just limited to your pods it
can also apply to the machine side
today we'll talk about auto-scaling
infrastructure with google kubernetes
engine
and cover some best practices let's go
beyond your gke bill
[Music]
in the last video we covered how auto
scaling works and
went over horizontal and vertical pod
auto scaling
if you haven't seen it i definitely
recommend checking it out since we'll
look at some additional ways that you
can configure auto scaling
and how that can help you with cost
optimization i'll start by going over
the cluster auto scaler and then
something really cool
node auto provisioning then we'll wrap
up with some tips to use when setting up
your auto scaling
so if pod auto scalers can help you
resize or add additional pods
what can you do with the infrastructure
side well just like the pod auto scalers
you can think of the same horizontal and
vertical options for infrastructure
this time we're talking about changing
the number of nodes
or automatically creating additional
node pools with optimized size
this is really where the cloud and
kubernetes work well together
since the cloud tends to give you a lot
more flexibility with your resources
let's start with horizontally adding
more nodes which is done by the cluster
autoscaler
the cluster autoscaler is designed to
add or remove nodes based on demand
but this time demand is actually based
on pod scheduling and requests
if additional pods aren't able to be put
into the existing nodes that are running
the cluster autoscaler will create a new
node so the pods can get placed
you can and should use the cluster
autoscaler along with the horizontal or
vertical pod autoscalers
that way as you create more or larger
pods
your infrastructure can grow alongside
them it's also important to note that
the cluster autoscaler is perfect for
cost optimization
since it's actually built to prefer
lower costs that means that the
autoscaler will start by trying to
create additional nodes of the cheapest
type
and then move to more expensive node
types if it can't create the cheaper
ones
isn't it great when cost optimization is
just built right in
just like the pod auto scaler having an
appropriate pond disruption budget is
important for having an effective
cluster auto scaler
the budget defines the minimum number of
running pods for your workload
so when the cluster auto scaler is
removing nodes
you can ensure that your workload will
still be running correctly
now there are some pods that can't be
restarted which will then block the
cluster autoscaler from removing a node
system pods like cube dns and pods that
use local storage
are examples of pods that can't be
restarted by default
for system pods you can set a pod
disruption budget which will allow them
to be rescheduled on another node
freeing up their original node to be
deleted but you may not want to set a
budget for some system pods that only
have one replica like metric server
since restarting them can cause
temporary disruptions
for pods with local storage you can
enable a special annotation called
save to evict to let the cluster auto
scaler know that they're safe to be
restarted
if you have any pods that are supposed
to run for a long time without being
restarted
you might want to move those over to a
separate node pool so they don't block
the cluster autoscaler
there's also a few more things to think
about when using the cluster autoscaler
make sure to figure out how to read the
cluster autoscaler logs
so that you can understand any
unexpected actions
if your workload can support it see if
you can use preemptable vms
since those will be prioritized by the
cluster autoscaler and
could save you a lot of costs but don't
forget to have a backup node pool in
case there's any trouble with creating
new preemptables when they're needed
set your minimum nodes by figuring out
the minimum capacity needed to keep your
workloads running without disruption
so you don't end up with idle modes so
the cluster autoscaler helps add and
remove nodes in response to pods needing
to be rescheduled
however gke specifically has another
feature to scale
vertically called node auto provisioning
node auto provisioning actually adds new
node pools
that are sized to meet demand without
node auto provisioning the cluster auto
scaler will only be able to create
new nodes in the node pools that you've
specified
this is perfect for helping optimize
resource usage for workloads and other
apps that don't need extreme scaling
since creating an optimized node pool
might take some more time than just
adding additional nodes
to an existing pool it's pretty cool to
have node pools created based on what
best fits your application
and as long as your apps support
interruptions you can save even more
costs by setting your pods to be
preemptable tolerant
allowing the audio provisioner to create
preemptable node pools
a few other things to keep in mind
consider how each of your auto scalers
will affect your apps
and make sure that you've spent the time
to configure each of them properly
new node pools can take a bit longer to
be created than simply adding more pods
or nodes so you may want to adjust the
metric value
of your horizontal pod autoscaler to
create additional pods
sooner set minimum and maximum resource
sizes based on what your apps need
so that the node auto provisioner
doesn't interfere with keeping your
workload
running with all four types of auto
scalers that we've talked about
there's a lot of configuration options
that you can use to customize your gke
clusters
effective use of some or all of these
can really maximize
your cost optimization but it's also
important to understand how long it
might take to scale resources
especially if you're expecting large
spikes let's walk through what scaling
up looks like when demand increases
for both horizontal and vertical pod
auto scaling they'll respond by adding
pods or resizing pods
depending on the settings that we talked
about in the last video on the
infrastructure side
if there's room on your existing nodes
that have already deployed your app
it might be able to skip pulling the
image and just start running the
application
if you're working with a node that
hasn't deployed your application before
a bit of time might be added if it needs
to download the container images
before running it but if you don't have
enough room on your existing nodes
and you're using cluster auto scaler it
could take even longer
now it needs to provision a new node set
it up and then download the image in
startup pods
if the node auto provisioner is going to
create a new node pool
there will be even more time as you
provision the new node pool first
and then go through all the same steps
for the new node
in order to handle these different
latencies for auto scaling you'll
probably want to over provision a little
bit so that there's less pressure on
your apps when scaling
up this is really important for cost
optimization
because you don't want to pay for more
resources than you need but you also
don't want your apps to struggle
let's go through two strategies for
figuring out how to over provision
using a pretty simple formula we'll
start with the formula you can use to
find an optimized target for using
horizontal pod auto scaling
the first thing we'll want is an
appropriate buffer target for the
application
to ensure that everything is running
smoothly let's choose a buffer size of
about 15 percent
so that we can keep the application
safely away from 100
cpu utilization then we can take a look
at the percentage of traffic growth that
we might expect in a two to three minute
period
here let's say that we expect a growth
of about 30 percent
with these numbers in the formula we can
calculate a target for the horizontal
pod autoscaler around
65 percent this generally means that
we'll be about 35
over provisioned in order to
appropriately handle the expected
traffic growth while still minimizing
extra resources
if you're using larger nodes and smaller
workloads with consistently less traffic
than requested
you could consider overprovisioning a
bit less since there might be room to go
above 100 utilization
the second strategy is to use pause pods
these are low priority deployments which
mean that they could be removed
and then replaced by high priority
deployments since these pause pods
aren't actually
doing anything they're basically just
reserving buffer
when the higher priority pod needs room
the pause pod will be removed and
rescheduled to another node
or a new node and the higher priority
pod has the room it needs to be
scheduled quickly
using these can help because no spin up
time can happen without affecting the
high priority pods
it's basically like scaling a little bit
ahead of when you need to
since they'll be spun up before they're
needed thanks to those low priority pods
it's a good idea to try and only use one
pause pod per node
so it's quick to be rescheduled the api
isn't overloaded with even more requests
and
the full node will be available quickly
alright
that's a lot to think about for auto
scaling and pause pod is really hard to
say
once again it's important to know what
your apps can handle and to optimize
around that
but you can also optimize your apps on
the next video we'll cover different
ways to do exactly that
remember to check out the link in the
description for the full guide on gke
cost optimization
you